Oh, we're bloody funny, aren't we?
Comedy gold.
Alright, well today we're
doing another Lenovo video.
This time, it's the ThinkPad tablet.
Check that out.
It's the limited edition
SpaceLab one, too.
Wait, are we going to chuck
water on this one as well?
No, that's old hat. And
also, it's freezing.
So we're gotta do a little
challenge between the both of us.
This tablet has an absolute
bumload of features.
And one of the cool ones is
that it will actually convert
your handwriting into text
using this little pen.
So do you have to use a pen with this?
Nope. You can use fingers.
You can use anything,
actually, pretty much.
More importantly.
Can you play Angry Birds on it?
Yeah, of course you can.
So here we are at our challenge area.
Right, so...
We have to run from here to over there.
Yep.
'Cross the garden,
whilst writing with this
pen on the ThinkPad.
"I heard various explosions,"
the famous quote from
my granddad over there.
I heard various explosions earlier.
Various explosions...
Various explosions.
Yeah. Nailed it.
Doesn't sound very hard, to be honest.
It doesn't, does it?
Make a pretty land video. as well.
So we're going to be blindfolded
and pelted with exercise balls.
So what happens to the
loser of the challenge?
Funny you should ask.
The loser of the challenge
has to hold up the tablet
while it's shot with this...
Whoa.
- ...fully loaded paintball gun.
I have really bad handwriting as well.
Yeah.
The winner is the one who
has the closest match to the
target sentence.
These are designed to absorb shock
and, you know, drops pretty well.
I wish the same could be
said for us, actually.
Yeah.
Trying to restrict the
blood flow to my brain?
A little bit.
I think I'll have a
better chance of winning
if your blood is off.
My blood is off, yeah.
I'm scared!
Three, two, one, go!
Well, Dan, I'm not gonna lie to you.
I'm in pain.
All over.
Scratches, bruises, it's the lot.
My head hurts.
I'm winded from my spinal
impact on the ground.
Oh, painful.
All right. Let's look at
the results. Here's...
This is mine, is it?
Here's you, first up.
Ah, it's not bad!
That isn't bad!
You got "I heard."
And "vav" from "various."
That's where you got hit by a ball.
It must've been, yeah.
Cause I got "I heard vav"...
Bang! Hit by a ball immediately.
And this bit I guess is...
It just all went to hell.
I think the tablet's
flying through the air
at that point.
Yeah.
Let's look at mine.
Oh, for God's sake!
Oh, dear.
That's awful!
Look, you've got "hrd" from "heard,"
and that's about it.
At least there's a letter
in the right place.
Why did you do that in capitals,
and then the rest not in capitals?
What is that about?
After I got hit in the head,
I forgot my... which applications.
It was like, yeah, yeah,
hit in the head. Ugh.
What, there's an X in there, though.
Oh, it's good.
At least that's in the word "explosion."
You managed to go .
Like that.
So it looks like...
I'm going to be the one holding this
when we shoot it.
Now, these ThinkPad tablets
are designed with special
gorilla glass on the front,
which is very hard to break.
Very tough.
Tough enough to withstand one of these
paintballs hitting it?
Direct hit?
Well, we're going to find out.
I think we should shoot the back first,
see if it works,
and then nail the front.
Then shoot you as well, yeah.
I mean, sorry. Just shoot that, yeah.
I'm scared.
Ah!
It just appears immediately.
As soon as I press the trigger,
it's like, "oh."
And then there's you, "Ow!"
Look, look. It hit me in the finger, look.
Watch it hit my finger.
Aw, it hit you in the finger
with a little bit of paintball.
That little shell of
paintball really hurt.
All right, so this one is
at 5,000 frames a second,
slightly closer in.
And let me just add,
I'm even more scared than I was last time.
You ready?
Yep.
Yep. Keep your eyes open. Bang.
Ow!
All right, so this is 200
and a bit times slower.
Check out my open eye.
Look at, you're like,
"oh, my eyes are open."
That's quality.
Oh, and it hit you there.
It went on my finger again.
That finger is like, the catchment...
It still just explods so quick, isn't it?
Yeah.
It's quite a lot of paint in those.
Let's nail the front.
Top head. Screen didn't break.
It's good.
All right, let's get one more central.
'Cause I'm not happy with that.
Check it out. Didn't break.
I didn't think it would.
Good.
Gorilla is hard at work.
Is that what it is, gorillas in the glass?
Like, microscopic gorillas in the glass.
Really?
Just going like...
Like punching paintballs.
Not true, obviously.
Had me going there.
Does it still work?
Still turns on.
Angry Birds still works.
You've got Angry Birds on.
It's all right, don't worry about it.
Angry Birds still works, it's OK.
Buttons?
Yep.
Top notch.
So if you're constantly
getting hassled by paintballs
or rogue exercise balls, as you do,
this is the tablet for you.
It comes with a noise canceling
pair of headphones and--
Oh!
A sling as well.
For sort of carrying it, you know, just...
A job done, I reckon.
Oh you're doing it!